dans cette salle de la batelière les
spécialistes de la maladie du diabète en
martinique
médecins pharmaciens infirmiers une
rencontre annuelle pour remettre à plat
leurs connaissances leur savoir faire à
propos de cette maladie héréditaire et
premier constat plutôt surprenant à
cause de notre mode de vie
mauvaise hygiène alimentaire absence
d'exercice physique il y en martinique
de plus en plus de diabétiques quand on
est parent diabétiques et déjà ce qu'il
faut lutter contre la sédentarité
l'inactivité physique et la mal bouffe
entre guillemets ça il faut vraiment
dans une dynamique d'avoir une bonne
hygiène alimentaire
ça c'est la meilleure prévention budget
alimentaire et puis faire de temps en
temps simple un dépistage c'est un bide
en une prise de sang avec son médecin
traitant pour voir si malgré cette
action de prévention que l'on entame et
on arrive quand même à la maladie
diabétique
des conseils que le monde médical répète
sans cesse et pourtant cette maladie
gagne du terrain
ce colloque qui ne dure qu'une journée
aborde donc les questions très précises
très technique mais on peut y voir
également
ces nouveaux appareils qui facilite la
vie des malades c'est bientôt presque
fini le temps où on se faisait une
piqûre pour mesurer son taux d'insuline
ce système qui permet de mesurer en
continu finalement le taux de sucre dans
le sang
donc on peut se passe en fait sur la sur
la peau qui doit 14 jours et ensuite on
va scanner on peut faire plusieurs
heures par jour
le patch en permettant d'avoir ici le
résultat donc rappel du glucose dans du
sucre dans le sang et adapter son
traitement est aussi un système ici qui
est un système qui couplé à ce qu'on
appelle une pompe à insuline donc la
pompe à insuline a donc du coup un
réservoir avec de l'insuline qui diffuse
en continu grâce à un petit moteur et il
ya un système ici qui posait aussi sur
la peau et qui va permettre de mesurer
le taux de sucre en permanence et ces
deux systèmes en communique jeudi
prochain 14 novembre c'est la journée
mondiale du diabète et durant toute la
semaine ces professionnels devront d'un
nouveau se retrouver pour apprendre à
mieux combattre cette maladie
lebel